after being summoned to a grand jury
former Trump aids Sam Nunn Berg went on
four different cable news shows said
crazy things and had a complete meltdown
yeah complete meltdown yeah when he saw
this performance President Trump was
shocked and said former Trump aide how
could I let this guy go
I got a good
he's on brand
he's on brand he's acting crazy I like
it a lot of people are quitting the
White House now and folks are concerned
well in an interview to calm everyone
down in an interview President Trump
claimed there is no chaos at the White
House yeah just on a pair of chimpanzees
crashed through the Oval Office on a
stolen snowmobile ignore that ignore it
today President Trump you know he's been
talking about tariffs you know big deal
today President Trump promised that his
tariffs on steel and aluminum would be
applied in quote a loving way yeah
congratulations President Trump you can
even make tariffs creepy tariffs off me
exactly in an interview President Trump
warned there may be more people leaving
the White House soon yeah after hearing
this prosecutor Robert Muller said funny
I was just about to say
the world's oldest message in a bottle
was found off the coast of Australia
yeah it's 131 years old isn't that cool
all the 131 year old message said was
you up
signed Larry King suspenders and glasses
that's the universal sign for Larry King
in Minnesota a 14 year old boy announced
plans to one day become America's first
Muslim president after hearing this
President Obama winked and said you mean
second
[Applause]
you